hi everyone my name is sai venom and I'm
with the IBM cloud team today let's talk
about Red Hat OpenShift on IBM cloud
first we'll introduce openshift open
shift as an open source application
platform based on kubernetes and
container technology it focuses on
making the kubernetes experience easier
for developers as well as operations
teams Red Hat open shipped on IBM cloud
allows you to focus on managing and
developing your application let us take
care of the heavy lifting with the
infrastructure allowing you to create a
highly available and managed open ship
cluster with the click of a button
together open shipped an IBM cloud
kubernetes service is the perfect match
providing you an industry-leading
developer experience for one will get
automated provisioning updates and
patching as well as 24/7 global support
currently we manage over 10,000
production clusters in IBM cloud
kubernetes service in addition you get
resiliency and security across the board
take advantage of highly available
masters to administer your clusters and
use options for dedicated compute and
bare-metal with multi zone regions you
get stability across datacenters further
enhancing your H a story on the security
front you get compliance out of the box
the things like HIPAA and GDP are
finally you get push-button integrations
with the entire suite of IBM and Red Hat
middleware build beyond those basics and
start taking advantage of high value
services like ai and hyper ledger
capabilities with the Red Hat and IBM
together we're building out a unified
open hybrid cloud platform whether
you're running on pram or in the cloud
taking advantage of kubernetes open
shipped server lists or CF technology
IBM cloud is unifying these choices and
bringing them under one management
platform powered by open container
technologies with the unified Red Hat
and IBM cloud platform start planning
out your open hybrid cloud strategy
today